засинаєш під канона до артилерії і ти
думаєш Ну я просто можу не прокинутись
бо всі були налаштовані вже на те що ми
з Маріуполя на повернемося ми ніколи її
нікуди коли ви виходили з Азов сталі 20
травня що Ви думали що вас очікує я
перебував в одиничній камері і досить
довгий час це просто нове завдання
завдання яке треба виконати просто треба
нищити ворога
Ілля Самойленко захисник України
захисник Маріуполя офіцер штабу окремого
полку спеціального призначення Азов один
із тих захисників Азов сталі які пробули
понад чотири місяці у російському полоні
Ілля повернувся додому у вересні Ілля це
велика честь по-перше говорити з вами
найперше хочу запитати як ви і Як ваше
здоров'я
дякуючи роботі наших лікарів та дякуючи
там тому що ми були Ми готувалися до
найстрашніших речей і ну це це не було
дуже сильним шоком в мене все нормально
зараз є здоров'ям Можливо там Як у всіх
трошки є стрес накопичений стрес але це
також не ті речі які можуть дуже сильно
нас підкосити і ми пропрацьовуємо всі ці
елементи та працюємо Ну я і інші бійці
ми працюємо над нашим відновленням та
повним повним поверненням до бою
готового стану Тобто це тут не є Ну тут
немає важких перепон є тільки просто
питання часу ви
Навіть зараз вас не зупиняють там якісь
психологічні травми якісь такі
переживання це вас не зупиняє взагалі
кожного з нас є певні психологічні
травми Просто ми про це можемо не знати
нема жодних виправдань та
причин для того щоб покинути обов'язок і
покинути
відступити від свого вибору Я свою вибір
зробив давно так і вирішив продовжувати
службу тому що я розумію що це я розумів
що тоді там багато років тому що це
потрібно ми в моєму суспільству моїй
державі та потрібен мені коли ви
виходили з Азов сталі
20 травня
що Ви думали що вас очікує
можливо це досить таке специфічне
сприйняття ситуації Так я не істину не
претендую але було розуміння що Ну ми
одне завдання виконали наказ був
виконаний на оборону от він був
відмінений і ми просто виконували інше
завдання а інше завдання було це здатися
в полон щоб ми могли евакуювати своїх
поранених тому що Ну вже починаючи з
кінця квітня ми розуміли що самостійно
територія Маріуполя ми покинете не
зможемо у нас повинні або забрати або
евакуювати от питання було в тому тільки
Хто це буде Хто це буде робити
Так вийшло що це робили російські
військові і ну наступне завдання в нас
було це ну здаємось в полон Окей тобто
була єдина причина для чого ми це робимо
тому що ну нас не було жодного іншого
варіанту жодного шляху для того щоб
врятувати наших а поранених А це було
близько 6600 чоловік
300 з яких були просто ну вкрай тяжкому
майже критичному
Ми сподівалися що буде можливий там
варіант з задіяні міжнародних там
якихось організацій там третьої сторони
наприклад Але знову ж таки
глибині душі ми розуміли що це просто ну
нереально ну росіяни просто цього не
допустять от Потім був полон от Ну також
наступне завдання яке треба виконати і
виконати і вийти вийти з нього Як Ви
думали скільки доведеться буде в полоні
Ну я взяв з собою зимовий одяг
Тобто
можна можна було розраховувати будь-що
от майже всі взяли з собою зимовий одяг
Я розумію що ви не можете розкривати
усіх деталей умов перебування тому що це
може нашкодити бійцям які досі
залишаються в полоні але наскільки
розумію ви перебували в одиночній камері
що вам допомагало триматися
складне питання дійсно Ну так я
перебував в одиночній камері і досить
довгий час
наодинці та в ізоляції
що допомагало триматися на розумінні
того що я маю продовжувати свою боротьбу
раз я розумію того що для чого я маю
продовжувати цю боротьбу це два третє
е-е сприйняття
прийняття того факту що війна чи не
закінчена і вона далеко від завершення
і четверте ну особисто ми йому
перебування в полоні вони не були е-е
дуже тяжкими так тобто ну умови були Ну
як я потім вже дізнавався там порівнював
з іншими людьми вони були відносно трохи
легші Але знову ж таки психологічний
тиск який надавався там через ізоляцію
так Ну деякі люди кажуть що це гірше Ну
можливо можливо
але я знову ж таки нема жодних
виправдань та причин до того щоб
покинути обов'язок тому щоб зупинитися
зупинятися я не буду і інші люди також
не будуть зупинятися тобто Ви відчуваєте
що це ваш обов'язок вижити вистояти
вийти звідси Я ж кажу це просто нове
завдання
завдання яке треба виконати не можна
підставляти командири не виконавши
завдання ви були в повній інформаційній
ізоляції вакуумі просто тобто немає там
зв’язку новин нічого ви виходите у
вересні у вас звільняють
перша новина яку ви дізнаєтеся
дізнаюсь і хороші новини і трагічні
новини От я дізнаюсь хороші новини за те
що скільки людей відмінено
трагічні новини я дізнаюсь що що
відбувалося за це літо
на таборі на ялинівці
Чесно кажучи в мене були песимістичні
прогнози там у березні у березні в
квітні в мене були досить песимістичні
прогнози їм це було викликано тим що ми
були в оточенні ми були в оточенні та
відриві від власних сил на там 100 км
було до найближчих
до найближчих союзних сил
і Це вплинуло на сприйняття ситуації
Тобто Ну ми ми ми тоді в оточенні
розуміли що ми можемо розраховувати
тільки на себе
на той бойовий склад який перебував
безпосередньо в Маріуполі
Коли повернувся
з полону я побачив що ми можемо
розраховувати вже не тільки на себе тому
що в першу чергу в тебе є таке поняття
Актив
і є багато людей які приймають участь у
війні які борються які воюють які
долучилися до силоборони і які також
вносять свій вклад в майбутню перемогу
також ну мене потішила кількість
знищених окупантів знищений ворожої
техніки
і я був приємно вражений тією цифрою
якою побачив тобто мої прогнози вони
були більш скромні
мене дуже сильно вразила
контрнаступальна операція в Харківській
області і зараз ну мені приємно читати
зведення про те що відбувається
наприклад ну на півдні країни там в
Херсонській області
сподіваюсь що це такі новини Вони не
будуть обмежуватися тільки цими
областями так і ми прийдемо до повного
контуру наступу по всім напрямкам
новини про мобілізацію в Росії не сильно
тривожать тому що я бачу їх рівень Але
знову ж таки навіть бачачих гривень це
ну Це мобілізовані це призовники але їх
дуже багато і все одно не можна втрачати
пильність ні в якому разі і це все одно
росіяни Ви повернулися у вересні в
доволі таки Мирний Київ Тому що з червня
не було навіть ракетних обстрілів Слава
Богу столиця саме
пан не видалося що люди відвикли від
війни те що повернувся в відносну Мирний
Київ це чудово Все факт Мені подобається
коли ми моє місто моє рідне місто в
порядку
ну дивіться Щоб те що люди відвикли так
має зворотню сторону якщо вони до цього
звикли Значить ми місто було б постійно
під обстрілами Так я цього не хочу чесно
я не хочу щоб мій Київ був ну
пошкоджений достатньо вже було
пошкоджень достатньо вже було так
[музика]
У вас є ж освіта історика вірно плануєте
завершувати обов'язково це один із
незавершених проектів які треба просто
зробити до кінця буквально кілька днів
тому ракета влучила у парк Шевченка
постраждав ось бібліотека постраждала
червоний корпус
Мені неприємно бачити що мої рідне місто
попадає під обстріл але мені приємно
бачити що люди від цього стають більш
злими до більш лютими і росіяни просто
роблять ту ж саму помилку яку рибу було
німці коли обстрілювали Лондон ракетами
фаул це має у зворотній ефект тобто вони
знищують цивільну інфраструктуру Вони
знають що вони роблять вони Б'ють
пожилим по житловим будинкам вони Б'ють
по по цивільному населенню і ну а люди
люди просто ще більше розуміють що війна
Стосується кожного І що війна не оминає
людей це є різниця яка відбулася ну
порівнюючи з 14-м роком що це десь там
не десь далеко а це тут прямо у серці
України там в багатьох інших містах
Я розумію що підйом патріотизму в
Україні дуже великий і я розумію
наскільки величезна та символічна роль
Маріуполя в цьому була
я мене зупиняю там іноді на вулиці ми не
впізнають так і було декілька людей які
мені просто сказали там Дякую за те що
ви зробили в Маріуполі Я кажу ми просто
робили свою роботу людина мені
відповідає дівчина ну я через це Через
те що там ви і казали Тоді я пішла
служити там і називає нам підрозділ свій
Я просто такий стою просто Ну дійсно Я
вражений розчулений і просто кажу просто
Ну вот Оце оце справжнє діло Дозвольте
трохи згадати події на азовсталі часто
побратими ваші згадують також оборону
азовсталі і кажуть що кожен день кожна
година
уже здавалось останніми що ще день і все
і це останній день у вас був такий день
коли здавалось що Ну все це кінець
безперечно у всіх були такі дні багато
було випадків коли ну ти просто ну
засинаєш під тканина до артилерії яка
просто б'є в в будівлю в якій ти
знаходишся От і ти думаєш Ну я просто
можу не прокинутись Ну і ти такий Ну
окей
більше разом не вмирати ну це фактично
так і є мало хто взагалі надіявся що ми
звідти зможемо вийти
ну всі розуміли що кожен день може бути
просто останнім там тому що може просто
не пощастити найбільш вражаючі моменти
можливо які вам запам'яталися
це здебільшого трагічні моменти і
будь-якої людини психіка їх блокує є і
безперечно більш такі які легкі моменти
позитивні позитивні так не складні
Наприклад
Це все що пов'язано з моєму побратимами
Ну це ми всі Браття
і
але ж знову таки чому психіки блокується
тому що я намагаюсь згадати приємний
момент і згадуючи цієї людини вже немає
і це стає вже не досить приємним
моментом і
ну Самі розумієте як це відбувається в
голові Я згадую прес-конференцію яку
видавали З Святославом паламарем велика
була прес-конференція для іноземних змін
для українських ЗМІ там дві години ви
тоді всіх вразили чудовою англійською це
було якщо не помиляюсь 8 травня ну тобто
це вже це вже такі бої йшли ну останні
фактично бої в яких умовах відбувався
цей ефір як це тоді все проходило ви
згадуєте це був наш
командний пункт був в бункері під одним
з цехів заводу
де я затиснувши телефон між колінами
сидячи на підлозі біля білої стінки
проводив словесницю прес-конференцію і
Ну тоді було і складно і просто водночас
складно тому що це надважкий надлюдські
умови перебування в принципі в бойових
діях ну такого виду це вже був
кінець третього місяця оборони Маріуполя
але в чому було легко легко було казати
про речі в яких ти розбираєшся тому Ну
дуже просто було там висвітлювати там
оперативно-тактичну інформацію там яка
Що відбувається на той момент ми
розуміли що
військові методи боротьби в Маріуполі
вже майже вичерпані тобто ми були Ну
противник переважав на кількість людей
Ну багато дуже багато разів була повна
перевага у повітрі у на морі е-е у
артилерії
вже фактично туди тоді не було Ми навіть
не мали чим відповідати Я також згадуючи
той ефір
я переглядав елементи з нього мені
показували так і я розумію що там багато
слів були сказані там Власне кажучи в
дуже критичних умовах в певному стані і
в дуже специфічних умовах От і я був
дуже ну трохи різкий в деяких в деяких
словах Але знову ж таки я не буду від
них відмовлятися тому що
Ну вони були сказані тоді в той час так
А час був дуже нелегкий наприклад ви
говорили тоді якщо не помиляюся ваша
цитата що керівництво адміністра
ситуація не змогли організувати оборону
Маріуполя Це скоріше було про оборону
півдня країни Але знову ж таки це
Деякі слова які я сказав це не є там
сфера мого це не є моя експертна сфера
Тобто там зважаючи на ту інформацію яка
там в нас була Так у нас
кажу тільки за себе так у мене склалося
думка що ось Ну це є так
до добре що це нікого не ображало тому
що не всі розуміли критичність моменту
от ну і типу ми всі були ми всі були
налаштовані вже на те що ми з Маріуполя
не повернемося но ніколи її нікуди тоді
закликали якраз до деблокади Маріуполя
ви вірили що можливо деблокада Маріуполя
ми вірили Ми сподівалися що вона можлива
але ну чесно кажучи ми розуміли що до
Блокада Ну вона майже неможлива хоча
знову ж таки рішучість рішучість
могла би в цьому випадку дуже зіграти на
на користь березні ви вже мабуть
розуміли що ви зупиняєтесь в оточенні ми
розуміли що ми опинились в оточенні з
перших днів
висвідомо на це йшли ви знали що ви
будете в оточенні
ми розуміли що за інших умов оборону
Маріуполя втримати буде неможливо Ну і
ми власне як як змогли підготувалися до
цього
ніхто не розраховував що ми
притримуємося там довше чи ніж місяць
навіть ми самі от але протримались
ви далі було б звісно протриматися до
підходу наших сил але ну ми також
розуміли що це дуже складна військова
операція яка потребує задіяні багатьох
ресурсів але Що відбулося в Маріуполі
найважливішими виграли час виграли
мінімум два місяці
того що Україна змогла оговтатися від
першого удару якщо ще повернутися трохи
до Маріуполя
барбувань бойових дій потім посиленої
російською пропаганди фейкових
референдумів Як ви бачите повернення
Маріуполя в Україну якщо взагалі бачити
Я як військовий бачу військове
повернення Маріуполя Це очевидно
відповідь тобто ну якби я був дипломатом
я би казав про дипломатичні варіанти Але
знову ж таки не в нашому випадку тому що
Росія - це терористична держава і жодних
перемовин не буде на інших мовах окрім
наших окрім остаточної капітуляції Росії
тому що ну В нас є одна мета - це
перемога у війні у нас навіть не так
скажу трохи в нас є загроза яку треба
ліквідувати ось ось що важливо і Росія
це є загроза для нас ми не зможемо співі
працювати з таким сусідом це неможливо
це неможливо не ну не не тому що я там я
хочу щоб це було неможливо Ні бо це
фактично неможливо мета росіян в цій
війні це не захоплення території це не
їх отця міфічна децифікація там де
мілітаризація як вони там кажуть це не є
закуплення українського ресурсу це не є
захоплення українських людей Ні вони
просто хочуть вирізати нас просто їх
бажання - Це продовження
продовження імперських традицій і це
видно по промовам там Путіна там та
інших їх придворних
це видно по їх
соціальному зрізу так по тому що думають
люди це видно там по документам у
соціальних мережах наприклад От і ну
кінцева мета росіян Так це винищення
українців от Але знову ж таки як вони
Вони почали винищувати українців з
російськомовних українців ну це
спільність
так от Ну за найменшим підрахунками в
Маріуполі вони знищили там близько 25
тисяч людей просто ну цивільних людей і
чим не вибірковими ударами Тобто це
навіть не не не на рівень там лимана
ізюма Бучі де собственно були Ну були
страти от Маріуполі Ну майже ніхто
нікого не страчував Наскільки я розумію
Наталя у вас
з Романів толкіна чарівник є злі сили є
орки у толкіна
виходить Гендель проти орків Ну типу
Якщо вам цікаво історія то це було
наспір з моїм університетським другом
Так і
причини до цього позовного були в тому
що навколо мене було багато бородатих
гномів але якщо повертатись до орків а
саме так називають росіян зараз в
Україні час от Як ви думаєте доцільно
називати росіян орками як завгодно ну
назва вже прижилася тому я не бачу
причин від неї відходити 14 жовтня День
захисників і захисниць України
щоб ви сказали українцям від імені
захисників України сказав що
зараз тяжкі часи
але в тяжкі часи не можна втрачати віру
в себе в першу чергу а якщо втрачаєш
віру в себе то вірю побратима от Тоді
йому буде краще І він зможе підтримати
тебе і підтримати вас вдвох окрім віри і
розуміння там своїх сил свого потенціалу
треба знати що навіть найтемніша ніч
вона закінчується і ніч найтемніша перед
світанком але окрім штампів та таких от
ідеологізованих політизованих враз
Можуть сказати що просто треба нищити
ворога просто знищувати ворога неважливо
де ти його побачиш не важливо де ти де
ти його зустрінеш в тебе просто
професійно експертну максимально швидко
з його знищувати щоб ліквідувати загрозу
для нашої країни Ілля Дякую вам за цю
розмову і дякую за те що зробили в
Маріуполі
ми просто робили свою роботу Дякую Дякую